[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's aaron rodgers the
packers quarterback and uh let me start
with that let me start with the obvious
question
is jake from state farm all natural
i know that we we didn't get uh drug
tested
um during that shoot yeah i think it's a
combination of a few things that you
might have seen
with another guy who's worn red in the
past tiger woods
um you know when tiger was was in full
workout mode
uh he may have been an xl and was
wearing a large
i think jake probably maybe a large guy
a t-shirt size wearing a medium to
medium small
it's medium yes medium yeah but you
never do you wouldn't stoop as low as
something like that
um no i don't think so i think
you know to uh to correlate i always
enjoy
like prime time games back in the day
watching our old fullback john [ __ ]
and he had a routine with the with one
of those uh
you know elastic bands that he would do
a lot of biceps before like a real
nationally televised game you know right
before the game to make sure that
his guns were as big as possible by the
time he went on the field wait
he did a party pump before the game oh
yeah a lot of guys do it though i'm not
going to just single out john there's a
lot of guys in the locker room that
make sure especially if it's a prime
time game you know their their arms are
looking as uh
as good as possible by the time they go
out there uh are you more concerned
with grooming on a prime time game than
you would be a sunday at one o'clock
probably yeah i mean i used to be
probably a little more concerned
uh i've let my facial hair go over the
years i'm not really cared if i'm
rocking a mustache or a beard
and uh if the neck is shaved now i can't
have the same type of neck beard as a
guy
you know like uh you know andrew luck
you know his just
will go down in history as as legendary
but
um you might maybe take a second look at
the nose hairs
if it's going to be a prime time game
compared to maybe at 12 o'clock at
lambeau well we talked about that before
where they'd have that stupid camera
angle where they'd be right up under
like how close is that camera right up
underneath you during the anthem
yeah i wasn't ever sure what angle they
were going for with that because
behind us is just the press box so i was
wondering why you would have to
you know insist on going at that angle
but
it is what it is that's come to league
that we've uh we've grown up in it's
more access the better for the fans
um and you also have to mouth the words
of the anthem
if the camera's on you don't you
i've seen guys do that before i never i
never really did that
um but yeah it's it's more of a
you know you when the camera kind of
gets in position you got to make sure
you have the
the face you want uh showing you can you
can't look uh
you know weird or anything you gotta
make sure that you know your game face
is is ready once that camera comes to
you just that red light on your scope
he's aaron rodgers joining us on the
program did you watch the monday night
game
i did not you did not do is that normal
that
unless it's an opponent future opponent
they're not interested
no i mean mr said it just depends on my
schedule and and how i'm feeling
um we had a longer uh a longer travel
uh to get back back you know playing the
afternoon game against andy got back
about 10 15 or so sunday so i try and
get to bed a little earlier on monday
and just kind of relax
during the day so i didn't uh didn't
stay up and watch it
i never knew this and maybe you can help
me separate facts from fiction
according to league sources packers
raiders were very close on a deal that
would have sent you to oakland and randy
moss to green bay instead of moss traded
to new england during 2007
and you stayed of course in green bay is
that true
i'm not sure if it's true or not i do
know that during that time i remember
where i was at i was on the 26th
in portland oregon with a friend of mine
and a couple friends of mine long time
friends
from when i was a kid and lived up in
oregon and
got a call from ted thompson and ted
wanted to reassure me that
uh nothing was uh was going on and i
wasn't going anywhere
so uh there were definitely some rumors
at the time
but doesn't that call make you nervous
that there was something going on for
him to call you to say
don't worry about hearing about anything
i'm not necessarily dan just because
you know it was i believe it was uh
before was it 06 or before 007
it says that moss was traded to the
patriots during the 07 nfl draft and
then
okay this was the spring of 2007 or like
the end of 2006
you know 2007. so i was still a backup
so
you know uh okay if i was straighted
um you know i don't at that time you
know probably would have been the worst
thing because i was thinking brett's
going to play a few more years and if i
get traded that means i might
be the guy right away so it wasn't like
the you know when his number came up
wasn't
oh man what does this mean it was like
oh okay well i guess we'll get to the
bottom of this right now
because you were probably 24 at the time
probably right just just turned 23
actually
okay and uh you know you start to look
at you know when when
and how much do you read or listen to
anything like honestly
like if espn comes on do you care if
they're going to go let's look at the
colts and the packers
or you turn the channel i don't really
watch that channel
um i mean it's it's never on at the
house unless
unless i'm watching my football and and
the sound is the sound is off so i'm not
i'm just not watching uh nothing
watching now i i will say this maybe if
kenny mayne is on and kenny and i have
talked
uh and he's gonna say something funny on
sportscenter i might switch over if he's
if he's doing the late sports center
um so i will admit that but uh because i
love kenny
but um really unless
unless uh tom here the packers gives me
a heads
up uh i don't see a lot of the stuff you
know or a friend of mine might say hey
did you see what you know
was written that no no what should i
look at it
you know they might they might send it
over but uh would you rather
read or hear something that was negative
or something positive like learn
something that might be considered
negative
or have somebody just say something you
know
verbal bouquets about you oh i mean i
don't think anybody needs to
at this point i don't need to to pump
myself up with some puff pieces
um and and you know spend time reading
and stuff like that
and i don't you know care a whole lot
about anything
on the other side of it really i mean
you know there's a job to do for
for those people uh i've railed at times
about how i think that the
you know the shock journalism with the
you know the
click bait headlines kind of rules the
uh
especially the online media but do you
care about legacy
yeah of course do you care where you're
ranked
all time or how people view you as you
know on the all-time list of
quarterbacks does that interest you
not really not at this point no i don't
think so i think the errors are so
different
uh i think a lot of people maybe uh
think about those things a little more
with lebron winning another championship
and
trying to compare him to michael and
michael the wilt and
kareem and russell and you know all the
great players of all time it's just
tough to
to compare generations so i don't you
know i don't get into that a lot
my legacy to me is more about like what
kind of player i was what kind of team
it was
um you know how i was the organization
the community that's just smart board
and also when you assess quarterbacks
now
i think everybody's going to throw for
60 70 000
it feels like whereas joe montana john
elway
you know i mean it was just different
back then if you threw 30 touchdowns
you had a hell of a season now if you
don't throw 30
it's almost like you're pedestrian here
how do you think the hall of fame voters
will be able to sort this out with
quarterbacks
yeah i think it'll be interesting to see
how they do it because i felt like
that for the most part it's been fairly
standard with
what gets guy in now with the longevity
and guys
you know and the numbers being bigger
than what they were in the 80s and 90s
and 2000s
when i really got into football
especially in the 80s and 90s
and the defenses and the offenses were
different the game was different and the
rules are
slightly different um i still think that
there should be a standard based on
being the best of your position
you know i'm saying top three to maybe
top five
for an extended amount of years you know
it's a consistency being one of those
top really top three guys i think at the
position
for multiple years in a row for large
stretches of your career i think that
should be
kind of the standard um i think there's
places for
uh you know guys who've had amazing
longevity and put up amazing numbers
um but i still think it the majority of
the guys it should be
you know you dominate your position you
know one of the three to five best guys
for
you know a decade or for an extended
period of time
uh that should kind of get you in i
don't know what is protocol but you
spent probably five minutes with philip
rivers on sunday like you actually had a
conversation with him
what what are you supposed to do post
game
you know what is protocol with two
quarterbacks after a game
i think it just depends uh depends on
how well you know the guy or
uh how you feel about him or how you
feel about
seeing anybody after the game um you
know we lost
obviously a difficult one there in
overtime coming back tying it
getting the ball back and turning over
and then and losing i just
i mean i really like phil i've known him
for a while
uh here and there and known him from
afar you know watching him play and have
a ton of respect for
for him and i just you know if the
conversation's easy you stick around
and that's it was it was good to you
know just pay my respects and
we can't ask you about his kids because
then you'll be there for a half hour
he's got
like nine or ten of them well it's funny
because i said
i said hey you guys working on number
nine yet he said you already had nine
looked amazing where have you been come
on oh yeah
behind i thought i thought eight was the
last one and maybe
uh aaron rodgers is a smart guy he's
using fedex
and he's getting his offensive lineman
their holiday gifts early this year new
traeger grills
i've been a traeger guy for years and we
love the traeger grill we i think i have
six traeger
grills out in our uh our barbecuing area
but uh
fedex dot com slash holiday guide
so your linemen know what you're getting
them yeah you know
last couple years at times there's been
some gifts that maybe didn't arrive on
christmas
uh maybe not even until the springtime
for a couple guys
so it actually worked out great to
partner with fedex so i could
you know shop for those things and then
ship them and get them early you know
it's before even thanksgiving which for
me is
is easily a record um but i'm excited to
you know take care of those guys and uh
you know fedex has been a great partner
and
it's fun to want to get those guys the
gifts
early so they can use them for
thanksgiving is the gift
better when you're better like when
you're like when you were mvp
one of one of those mvp seasons uh the
gifts better that year
i don't don't i don't think so actually
i think it's only been the last
seven or eight years where the gifts
have been really really good
um so how did they get you
uh every now and then they might give me
a bottle of scotch
wait is that what you were drinking on
draft night scotch or
tequila i was drinking tequila
[Laughter]
i mixed it up a little bit i like i like
scratch bourbon and some chip and
tequila that friend of mine got me on so
it was tequila that night did did the
glass get did you put more
in it when the packers were on the clock
or after
the packers were off the clock i would
say uh
after probably yeah but i didn't uh to
my credits
uh i didn't refill um
i started uh with the strong four
[Laughter]
i could just imagine you there that
you're you know you got tequila there
and the packers and they're going to
take a wide receiver here of course we
are
and the packers take jordan jordan love
did you know they were taking him prior
to the pick
uh no i found out uh just like we did
about five seconds before the uh
we made a t-shirt uh for you
we uh the uh last call with a tumbler
and uh we sent it over to the facilities
i don't know if you get the t-shirts
that we make that we send over to the
facilities
there they hold them in a secret vault
so
i don't know if they're worth that uh
once again uh
well fedex.com holiday guide and do what
aaron rodgers did he's doing it early
with fedex
delivering his offensive lineman holiday
gifts the new traeger grills
great to see again hope you're well
enjoy listening to you with uh mcafee
and uh thanks again for joining us
thanks buddy good to see you
aaron rodgers uh you can send your gifts
via fedex.com
holiday guide just like aaron rodgers
got him traeger girls